on attend
[Musique]
il faut que l'honneur et à l'itinérance
soit respectée et cette situation cette
nouvelle position des parlementaires
aveyronnais donc des représentants du
peuple m'amène à s'appuyer cette cette
décision c'est qu'ils tuent les coutumes
c'est quand des gens décident
aujourd'hui d'étouffer la vie des gens
mais ce trafic et la vie des gens de ne
pas fou et l'habilité des gens parce que
on est quoi exactement
si c'est pas seulement différent
[Musique]
en pleine pandémie autres il y avait
d'autres urgences à régler que le
pouvoir se donner en spectacle devant
l'humanité entière où tu sais pause
s'oppose à à l'homosexualité comme on a
pas poindre des choses qui vient de
l'occident pour l'amener ici chez nous
en afrique
le monde
[Musique]